-I'm always fascinated
to talk to mayors,
because, obviously, we spend
a lot of time on this show
talking about national politics.
And the people
there spend a lot of time
in their home districts
but, obviously,
a lot of time in D.C.
You spend all your time
living where you serve.
You live amongst
your constituents.
Are people always
coming up to you
and telling them their problems?
-Of course.
It's the most direct
democracy you can have.
I mean, people find you
at the grocery store.
People find you at the park.
I mean, they'll come up
to you and tell you anything.
You're, like, kind of
a confessor and a priest.
They'll say like, "Hey, Mayor,
I had a great date last night."
You're like, "Awesome!"
Or somebody will come up -- "I
had a terrible date last night."
"Well, let's talk about that.
Why?"
-Yeah. Did you run on
a dating platform?
-I did. I did.
-Yeah. Okay.
-That can be taken two ways,
but I'll...
-Yeah, exactly.
-No, I basically also have
my parents as my constituents.
So, you know, if you've had
a Jewish mother ever before --
Like, it's like
I'm at a community meeting.
They're like,
"The traffic's really bad
on the West Side of L.A."
I say, "I know.
My mom called me yesterday.
She had trouble
getting to my dad."
And, so, it's a
very accountable thing.
But, all joking aside, it's also
where politics still lives.
It's a place where
you can listen to people,
solve their problems, and
actually accomplish something,
which is so different
than what we see in Washington.
And that's not unique to L.A.
That's every local community,
I think, where we live.
So, you know, don't give up
on American politics
just because of what
you hear coming out of D.C.
-And do you think, in general,
there's more optimism and...
[ Cheers and applause ]
There's a better chance for
optimism and change
on a local level than
there is on a national level.
-Yeah. And, you know,
most politics happens
locally, anyway.
I mean, it didn't
matter whether it was gonna be
President Trump
or President Clinton.
Most of the work
you're gonna do on environment
is in your own backyard.
Most of the work
you're gonna do on jobs,
on education, on your
commute and transportation.
And people forget that,
because I think we cede a lot of
power to Washington, D.C.
But look at
these kids in Florida.
Like, that's
their local community.
There's more leadership
coming out of our teenagers
than coming out of
Washington, D.C.
And I also think
it's practical leadership.
People have strong beliefs
in our cities,
our local communities,
but they also want
to see the job get done.
They won't settle just for
a tweet, a re-tweet,
a counter-tweet.
They want us to actually fix
the street, like, do something.
-Yeah.
-And then the nice thing
about being a mayor --
if I don't fix it,
I'm on that pothole.
-So more streets, less tweets?
-Absolutely.
[ Chanting ]
More streets, less tweets.
More streets...
I like that.
-Well, of course,
one of the problems in L.A. --
You mentioned potholes.
Obviously,
traffic's a huge deal.
You guys have
the Olympics coming in 2028.
And I feel like this is
the first time in a long time
that I've heard
someone actually got a good deal
as a host city for the Olympics.
And you have an initiative
called Twenty-eight for '28.
-Yes.
-Is this about
public transportation
or just general traffic?
-Yeah, well,
we're the, unfortunately,
not only the car capital but
the traffic capital of America.
But voters -- The same
night that President Trump
was elected, there was
other stuff on the ballot.
And we passed
a $120 billion initiative
to build 15 transit lines in
L.A., where cars reign supreme.
And by '28 -- 2028 --
when the Olympics come,
we'll have 28 of
those projects done that are
improvements of roads,
new lines.
A lot of middle-class jobs,
too, that you can't export.
And I think people
talk about politics --
they say words
like "infrastructure."
What does that mean?
It means me getting home
to my wife, my daughter.
It means me deciding I can make
it to that date on time,
take that job.
We forgot to talk about
things in human terms.
So, we're accelerating all this
cool stuff for the Olympics.
I'm really proud that America
will get the Olympics back
for the Summer Games,
the first time since 1996.
And we're gonna
make money off of it,
'cause we have everything
basically built in L.A.,
from the Rams' stadium
that's gonna be coming up,
using UCLA as our
Olympic Village.
So we can focus on providing
sports to a bunch of kids
leading up to then and after.
-That's really exciting.
-Yeah.